[Music]
okay so this video will look at
seven older uh style sore prop practices
that maybe not seen so frequently uh go
through and
explain how they're done and demonstrate
okay
this first uh practice is
pretty much what turned into the first
of what
uh so it's various ways of doing it
uh it was it was originally i think done
up very close striking to the head and
it moved to strike the head into the
hands and then
striking to the wrist and then sort of
striking so you're missing the wrist
so if you're looking at it from uh
sort of benefits uh practice to benefit
perspective you really
want to be doing a full strike you don't
want to be pulling it straight
uh so probably the most beneficial way
of practicing this
is just strike to clear the wrist and
then anything else is
to uh it's just an adjustment
uh i think if you train where you're
constantly stopping and strike halfway
through it's probably not
the best way of doing things but i'll
just show you striking the head
first and then we'll strike to to miss
the wrist so he
basically raises that follow-up
and he's straight to there
striking to miss the wrist
[Music]
and that's basically there is all there
is to that
[Music]
okay so this is the second part of
practice it's a bit more
involved um
[Music]
just talk through it first so
i begin to raise and i'm kind of
initiating the move by giving you an
opening he
thrusts under my hands here okay
so i as he trusts under
[Music]
now from here i can strike very quickly
onto his wrist so he's exposing himself
here
so but he needs to then just move back
out of the way
and cover this position
so as i start this strike again you get
to cover it and i step forward and
strike the head
so i'm just starting the strike holding
back the posture and then
stepping it's a little bit tricky
that's the most so coherent way of doing
[Music]
it
okay so this is the third one
way he sets up for the
intended strike can be different you can
do it like the
equipment keeps even attached or you can
do it
uh for pure speed it doesn't really
matter
don't you know which one you're doing so
we just look at
uh the intended strike
initially so
he attacks i'm moving off the line
this is like the first do i say all the
first practices
we've done now he he can either take us
around
to step in for this strike or even take
it straight up
she's more like the keema super attached
but he's slightly slow
um whichever one you want to do really
as long as you know which one you're
doing why are you doing it
let's see it's a bit academic he doesn't
really
get to deliver it
[Music]
so that's the third part of practice
okay so the fourth part of practice is
it's a little bit trickier than it looks
we
break it down um
i like to do it so it sort of fits with
the feel of the
second kibitachi
thrusts so
in this one the you could argue but
there you go
so i raise the sword he
covers what he wants to do he's fighting
his way
toward me for the thrust okay
and what happens is i cross he goes for
it
drop under second thrust
[Music]
in case it's the fifth fun practice
first part of it is similar to the
second awase
and it's similar to the
chemistry and attach so
he strikes i move to the left
he didn't take the sword around you know
strike
here okay as he does that
like pick up
his uh forearm
okay so you need to beat that fairly
quickly and control him pushing buttons
[Music]
okay this is the sixth part about the
practice it's very similar to the
keyboard super attached um the way i'm
gonna
show it it's kind of slightly less
blending it's more
controlling from the defending side you
can do it
in a more blending way at the end if he
steps back i prefer to have
the feel of the finish so he starts like
the further i say
goes for the strike yeah that's
important he does actually go for the
strike not
just lifts and sort of becomes a passive
punch so he lifts the strike
he kind of gets an unpleasant jolting
feeling his body i hold this here and i
need to move out away
so he doesn't strike as soon as this
sword moves
and gives me clearance he will strike so
i'm going to move
so i'm clear and when i take the saw
there i'm also going to take it
across here so it will protect me
i can i could strike the head but i
choose to miss i'm going to strike
to miss the wrist now this is now like
the fifth part of the practice we've
just done
the exception he's got this leg forward
he then
goes to take up i'll pick the wrist up
in control as before
[Music]
is
okay so part of the practice this is
kind of like a new ruby
it's got it's uh two ways of finishing
[Music]
one is kind of like a favorite of mine
uh
so just talking through so
we're here i basically open up he just
comes
barreling in and i know what i'll do is
is flash that saw in front of him and
take it away so as he goes to cut
we're going to move so i'm stepping
here here okay
he just sees something flashy in front
of him and it kind of
it doesn't stop him but it slows slows
his cut down
yeah now i've now got two options
they're pretty similar really the first
option is just to strike
here and that if you haven't done this
sort of move
very much this is a great movie
hips hip move so if
you're less experienced i recommend
doing it like this
because this is a really nice training
move you've done it a few more times
cut and then you bring this leg back
to here that's where his head bounces
on the floor and rolls into the corner
[Music]
okay so that's the uh seven part
practices
they're not seen quite so
frequently nowadays
it's sort of a good practice for the
keemstar attach and we'll be doing a
video of that later on for him okay hope
you enjoy this and learn something
[Music]
you